I don't want to talk about no cuz I used
to be a whole thing of all morning I
used like money like motive other than
figure war we used to you did yeah I did
imagine my get two grand every night I'm
sorry as I can you imagine making 3
grand every night you made 3 grand a
night and figure huh yeah how'd you do
that
how many guys is that that's a lot
that's a lot so how do you go from
figure out down to here
how'd your name sweet you were mating
3009 on Figaro and now you're here on
Skid Row
how do I get down here shoeless on Skid
Row how you doing run away from it
didn't have any dudes crack oh no a
phone well your eyes yeah I go wait
sorry what nobody else get wait you got
read recently yeah my mom my mother
she's um ex-boyfriend Todd his name's
tattle he choked me he covered my mouth
he just it was horrible
all right like I said I don't wanna go
through what I just went through
yesterday
ok top tonsils be all swollen up that's
all swollen up because you can't talk
get off of him mr. month he was high he
was high it was too high I think you
know you telling us you don't call
police he gets kids and run off so we're
here today you're living there tensed oh
yeah no student it
not enough alone well hopefully God give
me a give me apartment I sister him
don't want me Gallagher no more thank
you well I fear the bank I raise she
talked I talked to him at the on the
bunch
she's gonna give me from down here if I
don't get from now here she's gonna come
get me
well you everybody now huh were you
doing for money now I want to start
doing everything there's not a lifestyle
was last time he had arrested ever been
arrested or all time in China the
diversity time wildlife for you just
work late there huh you still work with
a pimp I'm gonna kill ya a while ago
yeah that was a long time ago
that's what a little blue those words
with twist my man and I right now he's
not no pill that's not I'm posting
posting him husband I made period I
don't share them I don't do nothing he
stayed home he got there make his money
I make my money we put it together we
get loser team no pimp in here I do it
because I want to do it
wait where do you see your life going in
I know I see my life with it make sure
as hopefully I'll be in my apartment you
know hopefully I have my own apartment
my kids back and go back to school the
kids are where I know a New Yorker no
sister oh yes yes that's my goal is to
keep myself together and to get my
babies back cuz I need them no I didn't
put my kids or - you know I didn't know
that I wanted my babies I was [ __ ] up
smoking too much with my daughter what
we smoke okay I'm smoking house for me
and my water broke and I had my daughter
you know at the terminal at the Cecil no
tell how many years you've been living
on the street Oh
obedience houses I was 17 held you know
36 every 37 days or you're still using a
little bit
hello but not that bad like I used I
must stop doing everything
is that dis lifestyle is not to say any
more good to me if you can kiss mine
okay dude is no no it's a hard life
right yeah
okay do another I'm getting oh okay okay
do it no more so if you get a housing
down here and you bring your kids down
here you think that's a good environment
for your kids I'm not no kids down here
because I don't want them now here lies
you're gonna play somewhere else I want
to go somewhere else where there's no
drugs my kids have a normal life I have
a normal life everybody be happy I just
wish I could just change the whole world
stop everyone from smoking crack they
just start make everybody oh ho do you
think there was something in your
childhood that set you on this path led
you down here but my child
yeah I came down here I was 17
yeah but was there something in your
childhood it's kind of like I think
something's telling me to come together
for a reason I did because his kids his
teenagers my my age was my age right
it's going through the same situation
that I went through so maybe is the
reason why I'm down here to show them
the way to get it to get out through
these videos to the videos thank you
somewhere is gonna see this right
somebody's gonna see it make my kids
maybe somebody else maybe who knows
maybe somebody in this lifestyle but
look at these movies shows my story and
changed a life for her
that'd be great you're doing a good deed
by telling your story yeah
I'm trying to help them show them what I
can do I wouldn't want them to go
through because what kind of things have
you been through been through
prostitution I've been faucets in every
weight I mean betta a [ __ ] so i
misdoubt
prison i'm never been a person to jail
I've been to County and we know that you
know when you've been robbed
huh you've been robbed I've been robbed
to the attempt thank you a lot of
horrible stuff I miss dad when I was six
months pregnant my daughter I don't want
nobody go through it
that's it Kazakh - I thought it's a
terrible boyfriend
yeah the Turner line oh yeah my ex
hasn't got you thought that he died from
ammonia no he didn't die for me what
would you say to a ten-year-old girl
look at your video what would you say to
her I tell you all the way it's one girl
girl whatever travel 12 do not go
through this lifestyle don't let no pimp
pimp you don't let no man tell you
what's right from wrong don't nobody
control you've got your own life
you know what to do do what's right
what's wrong and stay in school you get
definitely gotta stay in school that's
it in school I got a high school diploma
but stay in school get your life
together don't have no kids don't
definitely have no kids
oh you say this young voters say to
young parents that are like maybe
considering splitting up and they okay
let me tell you parents could I been to
it
my dad left my mom when I was 17 when I
was a baby
Paris y'all definitely gotta stick
together for your kids that's a big one
right that one that's deep come on mama
my dad he left my mom when I was baby I
never met my dad he said oh when you're
very small it was very small small small
so your dad was out of the picture then
yeah he was out of tune
I can tell you right now I'm parents
your parents got a stick with a stick it
together that's the only way do you
gonna stay together and that's for them
kid Oh some kids you guys stay together
for the kids yeah they're words of
wisdom Candace yep make your ride the
money with all that Amy this is a okay
you